muy cerca de otro doloroso hito para
eeuu hace un año cuando el virus apenas
hacía su aparición en el territorio el
entonces presidente prometía un rápido
regreso a la normalidad va a desaparecer
un día es como un milagro desaparecerá
pero muy pronto nueva york se convirtió
en epicentro de contagios en el país el
sistema sanitario y las funerarias
estaban colapsadas los trabajadores de
salud al límite
yo no quiero disculparme porque estoy
haciéndolo lo mejor que puedo pero si no
es suficiente lo siento mucho realmente
lo siento
una escena que pronto se extendió a toda
la nación muchos estados se mostraron
reticentes a adoptar cierres y
restricciones y en un año electoral el
porte de mascarillas se convirtió en un
símbolo de una postura política
maybe we are creo que quizás hemos
fallado a la gente al no conseguir que
todo el mundo se sume y creo que la
reticencia por adoptar la decisión de
llevar tapabocas y proteger a todo el
mundo es un mecanismo de supervivencia
de nawal donald trump contrajo y superó
el virus pero su pobre manejo de la
pandemia fue un factor clave para que
los estadounidenses confiarán en joe
biden para traer un nuevo enfoque desde
la casa blanca
me emociona ver para curar debemos
recordar a veces es difícil recordar
pero así es como sanamos zawiya
concentrado en la esperanza que traen
las vacunas eeuu y aplicado más de 60
millones de dosis casi un 20 por ciento
de su población sin embargo el panorama
aún es sombrío el instituto de métricas
y evaluaciones de salud estima que más
de 615 mil personas podrían haber muerto
para junio